咱接着录啊，刚才录着录着没电了，也不知道，后面一整段都白录了。嗯，咱从爱情片这里接着说刚才说了这个金羊毛类，我们说小蝌蚪找妈妈，他先天就是个金羊毛，他找妈妈呀，先天就是金羊毛类型的片子，我给他举例子了。
我们说还就是小蝌蚪找妈妈。
可以做成爱情片吧。
可以做成爱情片吗？
当然可以。
爱情让我说。
爱情片往往就是爱情元素，你懂我意思吧？爱情故事啊就是这两个主角之间它符合爱情或者兄弟情或者友情，它符合这个爱情元素，它往往就是。
可以让你。
现有的类型片更更更厉害。
爱单单的爱情。
故事已经很难成篇了。在当下这个年代。
那我们来看小蝌蚪找妈妈这个事儿。
我们说这个小蝌蚪跟他这个王八这个好兄弟呀。
跟他这个好兄弟啊完全就可以做成爱情。
或者做成兄弟情。
或者做成异性的这种爱情，反正是感情片可以做出来。
明白这个意思吗？
蝌蚪跟王八。
我们来看啊，如何加就他目前还是个金羊毛片，他是就是一对好朋友上路。
如何把它变成爱情片儿？
人家教我们方法了呀。
就本方法了呀。
完全可以做掉。首先呢残缺的主角。
你小蝌蚪现在不残缺呃，不够残缺。
对吧。
完全可以让他更残缺嘛。
残缺的主角，然后。
另外一一半呃那个那个配角是它的零件。
小蝌蚪咋餐去？
小蝌蚪没有尾巴。
他也不可能再缠别的了，在身上周身上下就一条尾巴，一个一个一个小蝌蚪是吧？那他就没有尾巴嘛。
它就剩一个点儿点点哎点点点点，你怎么了？点点我点点没有尾巴，它周身上下就一个器官，就是尾巴，然后它没有尾巴残缺。
没有尾巴，他就失去了行动能力，失去了捕食能力。
失去了保护自己的能力。
他等于就是残缺的主角，一个没有尾巴的。
小蝌蚪。
那另外一个主角。
就是王八。
王爸呢？
我们说他是小蝌蚪的。
他是小蝌蚪的。
尾巴。
对吧他。
驮着小蝌蚪找东西吃，驮着小蝌蚪散步，驮着小蝌蚪看日出，驮着小蝌蚪走来走去，他相当于弥补了小蝌蚪。
我们说它必须是个零件，就是说它除了驮着小蝌蚪之外，它应该别的作用尽量压低。
小蝌蚪只有一个头啊。
只有一个头啊，所以小蝌蚪可能心思比较多，思考明白我意思吗？心思比较多，他只是没有尾巴，他心思很多，那么我们就会玩八就可以。
可以弱智吗？
明白我这意思吧？就是这个王吧可能。
比如说这个这个。
呃，他们这个池塘里之前有人炸鱼，往往往池塘里扔炸弹。
这个网吧曾经被。
严重的脑震荡，所以现在有点。
有点愚蠢，就是有点一根筋。
然后呢，他就每天就驮着这个小蝌蚪。
那么他们俩就完全成了残缺的主角跟灵件的关系。
这就有了爱情片的底子了。
明白这个意思吗？
互互相需求，互相圆满，互相弥补的这个作用已经达到了。你前面再烘托一下，他们俩是如何的相遇，如何的你帮助我哇，我帮助你如何的在一次危难的时候，王八曾经救过蝌蚪，然后再一次有人掉来钓王八的时候，蝌蚪还掉。
救我王吧，因为他聪明啊，他看出那是个鱼钩啊。
把他俩这个互相需要。
做出来，观众就马上认为他们俩就天造地设了一双呀。
就是互相弥补呀，然后第一步达到了，第二步开始拉钩。
爱情片嘛拉高了。
就像他俩不能在一块儿。
不能在一块儿。
我们说这个沟壑呀是爱情片的关键。
我不是说过吗？这个这个这个传统的爱情片里面一般都用生死。
阴阳两隔那个最狠了，对吧？在一起得死。
我们这个能做到吗？
可以。
为啥你这跨物种更更简单，他们俩一个是王八，一个是是是是青蛙呀，对吧？
很简单。
王八吃青蛙呀。
甲鱼。
假鱼吃青蛙呀，在池塘里。
你知道吗？
然后甲鱼慢慢的快露出他的本性，他会去捕捉别的青蛙，然后小蝌蚪自己慢慢变成了一只青蛙。
他会发现两个人之间的误会。
城建。
价值观。
区别越来越大。
对吧他会眼睁睁看着这个王八去捕食别的青蛙。
这个王八嘴上再说对他好，他始终没有这个安全感。
他会觉得是个威胁，然后开始挑毛病，开始觉得你歧视我。
你拿我当你生活的附庸而已。
然后两个人开始。
产生了决裂。
然后你如果想加深这个沟来王爸的家人呢？
这个王八这个王八他家里人呢？
他家里人肯定说，哎，这有个现成的游不太动的青蛙吃了呀。
对吧？然后青蛙又听到了，说他们要吃我。
我呢。
游的这么慢，我笨鸟先飞。我知道他们明天要吃我，我今天晚上就走吧，明天再走。
后面蹭了一下，那王八的他脑袋蹭了一下就给你咬过去了。我今天就走吧，所以他不辞而别，那不辞而别。
他就没有听到，其实他的好朋友。
拿命在保护他。
不惜跟家庭决裂。
所以他们俩的沟壑很深的，既关乎生命。
又跨越种族。
你如果围绕着这个沟壑，他们俩之间如何产生误会，如何决裂，如何在在。
在消逢去做的话，那他就是一个。
标准的爱情片。
这就是一个爱情片，小蝌蚪找妈妈就变成了一个爱情片。当然也可以把这个小蝌蚪跟王八的这段爱情。
安在。
金羊毛。
里面。
就他俩一块上路去寻找。
他的身世。
只是把爱情做进去，懂吗？这样二合一这个片子就更强了。
所以爱情片懂了吗？如果是小蝌蚪跟这个王八之间做成爱情，完全可以，当然也可以独立成片，那这个片子就很浪漫。可能这个这个蝌蚪跟王八的爱情就纯爱片子啊，只能吸引女性观众。
强直男是绝对不看的。我跟你说，作为一个直男，我告诉你强直男绝对不看爱情片，什么练练笔记本，哎呀，这去你的吧真。
真的看不下去。
好吧，爱情片明白了吗？
这就叫爱情片，把它做残缺，把做零件，其实就是让观众不停的暗示明示给观众，他那么俩缺一不可天造地设，谁离了谁都不行啊。等观众认可了说，对呀，确实谁离了谁都不行，咔嚓给他俩分开拉一条沟不行，他俩不可能在一块儿。
然后观众就着急了，为什么呢？你看这就是女性观众，对吧？男性观众就他妈耍我呢。
不在一块儿就不在一块吧，重新找一个呗，对吧？男性关女就可以这么想。
你看爱情片明白了吧？
爱镜片啊。
也搞定了。
我们再来看超级英雄片。
小蝌蚪找妈妈。
能不能写成超级英雄片？
超级英称四要素啊，能力命门对手使命。
那他要超级英语边，他至少得是个蝌蚪精啊。
是吧我们说蝌蚪侠。
蝌蚪侠。
蝌蚪侠呢它具有什么能力呢？
可能基本上的海王那一套他都会啊。
对吧在水里任意的钓起来，水里的这个虾兵蟹将，任意的运用水水的能力还可以水炖，碰到水啪的就。
进去了，他至少得拥有这个能力啊。
对吧拥有这个能力。
你就得有个命门能制约他。
能制约他。比如说这个蝌蚪侠，他有什么命门呢？
最好的最简单、最通俗的命门。
比如说他不能离开水超过。
15分钟。
这样的话你设一个时间锁，你可以经常养发命。
离开水，敌人可以洞悉这个秘密。
对吧因为这个命门需要有一个知情人。
会被对手知道的这件事情。
就是把它。
至于一个完全没有水的环境。
看你怎么办，因为他每隔15分钟要变回原形补一次水。
像这种命门就很好用，因为它可视化。
15分钟多长时间了，对吧？这次蹭的变成那个那个蝌蚪侠去去去去拯救一个小女孩，开始上来先救猫咪嘛。就你别看你是蝌蚪，你也得救猫咪啊，上来先先先救救人什么的。
把这个15分钟这个规则交代一下。
简单设置的话，这个命门就挺好的。
每次变身5分钟吧，比如说每次变身变身5分钟，5分钟一到你就得赶紧补水，要不就就干了，变成葡萄干了。
蝌蚪侠，我们说他有能力了，有命门了。
得给他设置一个对手。
对手我们说是什么来着？旗鼓相当啊。
旗鼓相当必须是旗鼓相当的对手。
那就是王八精呗。
这个王冠君是他的对手。
对吧王大金跟他对着干。
嗯。
这个。
他的使命我们说一个超级英雄之所以称为超级英雄片，它的使命必须是大的，不可能是说是报个丝绸啊，或者是那个呃这个这个两个人因为有点什么事儿有矛盾呀，这这个不可以的这不可以的。
使命。
就是。
他可以用丝绸入手。
比如说他。
小蝌蚪找妈妈嘛，对吧？他发现自己的妈妈。
就是被。
这个王八给。
太了。
被娃娃精给害了。
然后通过去调查这个王八精，进而发现王八精有一个惊天大阴谋。
有一个惊天大阴谋。
比如说他要。
统治整个水产界。
对吧他要。
他要制霸整个水库。
这对于他们来说是整个世界。
那么小蝌蚪。
这蝌蚪精就利用自己的这个能力。
跟他的对手。
展开殊死搏斗。
这就是一个超级英能片。
他。
有能力、有命门，有对手，有使命。这种片子很简单。
很简单。
明白了吧？
我们说小蝌蚪找妈妈可不可以是一个。
鬼屋片呢。
鬼屋片。
股片也有要素啊，有诀窍呀，空间。
力量原罪。
我们现在就来设计这个嘛。
空间很简单啊。
一个小水塘的。
一个封闭的小水塘子，经常有那种啊下雨天的时候，那蝌蚪到处下籽儿啊，那青瓜其到处下籽，然后等干巴了以后，有时候一个轮胎印儿里面就有很多。
那个那个小蝌蚪。
我们说一个小池塘。
嗯没有活水的那种小吃堂，蜂闭的。
一个封闭环境吧，一个封闭空间。
然后。
一个力量。
小蝌蚪不都是溜边吗？在那个。
河燕的那个那个池塘堰的那个草草那里在浅水区。我们说深水区有一个。
有一张黑的嘴。
一直在吃蝌蚪。
这就是一个力量。
一个空间密闭的空间。
很不大的一个池塘，但是也有浅水区、深水区。
一个神秘力量，深水区有一张血盆大嘴。
在。
吃蝌蚪吃青蛙。
对不对？
原罪。
原锥也简单，小蝌蚪找妈妈吗？小蝌蚪因为调皮，不听妈妈的劝告，非要到深水区里去嘚瑟一下。结果血盆大口突然出现，妈妈为了过来救他，保护他，被血盆大口拽走了。
消失了。
咕噜咕噜冒了几个泡。
这就符合一个恐怖片，一个鬼屋片。
需要的元素了。
一个。
本来。
欢欢很快乐。
很天真的小蝌蚪。
生活在一个密闭的。
小水塘里。
妈妈千叮咛万嘱父要老老实实溜边。
吃点草，吃点浮游生物。
呃，快快长大离开这个地方，因为在深水区有一张血盆大口。
他没见过这个雪盆大头，他不信呀，调皮呀。
然后非要到深水区去嘚瑟一下。
见识到了这个力量来追杀他。
在非常危机的时刻，他妈妈游过来了，挡在了他跟血盆大口之间。
被血盆大口拽走了。
拽到深水区，咕噜咕噜冒了几个泡。
消失了。
空间力量原罪就是你的原罪，就是你把你妈害了。
你这时候不鼓起勇气去找吗？
一定要去找的一定要去找的。
他经过一夜的痛苦。
第二天踏入了深水区。
去找他吗？
发誓要找到那个血盆大口。
但是肯定也害怕呀，因为他他很娇小的呀。
要躲着在石头缝里躲，对吧？慢慢的摸黑前进。
想想办法找伪装，找隐蔽。
对抗这个。
靠自然的力量那血喷大口。
极有可能还是那只大王吧。
是吧。
鬼屋片。
明白了吗？
就是这么写的，好吧。
我们说真大片。
真他们点。
如果是小蝌蚪找妈妈。
侦探片该怎么设定？
叛秘者。
毫无质疑是小蝌蚪，因为小蝌蚪找妈妈嘛，这个标题就先天带着一股揭秘看蜜的那种感觉。所以主角毫无疑问还是小蝌蚪。
小蝌蚪，那么秘密。
就顺着找妈妈来，谁是你妈妈？
对吧谁是你妈妈？
他有这样的秘密。
他要去探究。
他要么不知道谁是自己的妈妈孤儿，他要么怀疑现在的身世是假的。总之，他作为一个。
探秘者他要探究这个秘密。
谁是我爸？
谁是我嘛？到底谁是我嘛？
最后的自我牺牲。
自我转折自我自我对抗这里。
什么呢？
就是。
这不是一个侦探片吗？就是你找到了你的生母。
同时发现。
他是个坏人。
他是个十恶不赦的人。
那你会怎么选择？
你作为一个警察，你作为这个池塘的警警察。
你你利用你的职务之便。
对吧利用你的职务之便。
侦查凶手，一边侦查凶手，一边找你妈。
但是你发现。
这个凶手。
就是你妈。
这个丧心病狂的女女魔头。
就是你的生命。
他开始连你都想杀。
后来他发现你是他儿子以后。
他跟你。
老母子壳。
对吧让你放他一马。
让你高抬贵手。
他保证以后不打扰你的生活。
放他一条生路。
就是。
我有生你的恩，虽然没有养你的义，对吧？但我有生你的恩。
我们今天也算见着了，母子相见，你放我走。
以后桥归桥路归路。
他作为一个探秘者。
吃到了这个命运。
也找到了自己的母亲。
他这时候应该怎么选？
一定是自我牺牲呀。
一定是。
我终究还是个警察。
亲手。
送他妈妈。
上段投台。
这就是一个侦探片。
他最后要的结果。
就应该是一个很残酷的结果。
让他做出自我牺牲的结果。
凶手。
这么做这个片子起活。
我们来看这一这一排。
这5个。
这5个就比较。
太美了。
我们说每一种类型啊区别不大，有好几个可以直接卡。我说的小人物出大事儿，明白这个意思吗？
但是你要仔细去。
去分呢，仔细去按照呃这个呃呃。
施耐德先生。
提的这种讲故事的分法，分的这种类型也可以。
因为人家毕竟也是大师，明白这个意思吧？我们不要去随便质疑，我们可以保留意见，不要去瞎质疑好吗？
来如愿以偿想。
如愿以偿行有几个元素啊，就是你有一个。
情有共情的愿望。
就大家都能听得懂的怨乎。
然后呢，实现这个愿望是需要有规则的。
也就是说是要有咒语的。
代价的有条件的。
然后最后你通过有条件的实现了你的愿望之后，最后得到一个教训就是。
珍惜眼前人，珍惜当下，现在这样挺好，要什么自行车？
我说了，这就是如愿以偿现电影的基本套路。
那么我们来小蝌蚪。
我们可以搞成穿越嘛，我说穿越片子。
这个这个这个可以是。
大家很很有共情的一个愿望，穿越是很有共情的一个愿望呀。我经常幻想，我要我要是回到我20岁的时候，重新来过，我会走对哪几步，懂我意思吗？
这个共情很强烈的来，那我们就让他穿越。
走穿越路线。
小蝌蚪。
穿越回童年。
说当年有一次选择。
对吧比如说。
当年经过一个河岔口的时候。
有一次选择他可以去大海里冒险。
他没有去。
然后你现在让他穿越回童年。
让他实现当当时的愿望。
给他一次重新来过的机会，不管是什么规则啊。
穿越回童年了。
那这就是愿望。
村友会当年少年时吧，少年时的那次选择，他可以呃到大海里去看一看，他错过那次机会了，人生终身遗憾嘛。
让夏洛特烦恼一样。
跟秋雅试一试嘛，他就想跟秋雅试一试嘛。
对吧他觉得自己被马冬梅给耽误了嘛。
来小蝌蚪想去大海里试一试，觉得自己被小池塘给耽误了。
咒语是什么？但设定一个咒语啊。
设定了咒语。
一般的穿越片啊一般设定了什么咒语啊？
就是你不能改变历史的进程。
能，明白这个意思吧？
不能改变历史的进程，经常设这种咒。那我们这个小蝌蚪就。
当时去到大海之后。
就是穿越回去之后，他不是如愿去到大海了吗？如愿去到大海了吗？
然后。
在大海里干扰了历史的进程了。
干扰历史进程大海，比如说当时有个什么比较重要的事儿。
那个。
哪吒闹海比我。
哪吒正好在那跟龙王的三太子干仗。
然后呢，他从那儿过。
把这个事儿给搅了。
把哪吒拌了一个跟头，结果是三太子把哪吒给扒皮抽筋了。
等于彻底改变了历史。
然后。
他在这个事件中需要完成的任务就是。
呃，重新把历史回到正委。
对吧？
没把别把哪吒给杀了啊。
给哪吒办了一个跟头，导致哪吒没有干掉龙王三太子。然后龙王三太子呢就在海里。
他是个恶少呀。
他是个很嚣张的富二代人。
然后龙王三太子最后迅速继承王位，继承王位以后呢，就开始残暴的统治海洋。
把海底的那些呃鱼虾呀什么的海豚、鲸鱼什么的折腾够呛。
全是因为他当年。
重新选择误入海洋，绊了哪吒一个跟头，导致哪吒没有收服这个残暴的龙太子。
那等于他在。
这个大海里。
需要纠正这个事儿，罪孽老大了，闯大祸。
闯大祸了。
最后。
给他一个教训。
就是珍惜当下。
珍惜当下，他完全可以在纠正这个事情的时候，再次回到自己。
生它养它，生活了一辈子的那个小池塘。
去听听妈妈的意见。
妈妈当年不让你去大海。
是有道理的。现在你置身在大海，你感觉你自己是个人物了。
闯出了如此滔天大祸。
有什么解决办法，世界都乱了，没有解决办法，你觉得一头雾水，没有一个对策的时候，你去听听妈妈那些最朴素。
最简单的道理。
说不定反而找到了。
解决的办法。
这就是你得到的教训。
得到的教训。
珍惜当下，珍惜眼前人。
不要好高骛远。
合理的蛤蟆。
别别下海。
对吧你是河里蛤蟆，别下海。
这就是如愿以偿类型，我们可以搞个穿越，明白吧？